I was 21 when I wrote that song I
thought it was about a different no John
Mayer finally reveals who inspired his
2001 Track Your Body Is a Wonderland
[Music]
and his answer will surprise you it's
how we all made records John opens up to
Alex Cooper on the call her daddy
podcast and dishes on the hit song you
were dating someone at the time that
you're writing this iconic song which no
I wasn't you weren't no that was about
my first girlfriend fans have long
speculated that John's track is about
Jennifer Love Hewitt they dated around
the time of its release
status relationship is as much as a
relationship between two people who
really really like each other could be I
think she's amazing she's gorgeous she's
a sweetheart too and while Alex didn't
name names John swooped in to set the
record straight that's one of those
things where people just sort of form
that idea it gets reinforced over the
years no no no I had never met a
celebrity when I wrote that so there you
have it people Your Body Is a Wonderland
is about John's one and only high school
girlfriend and he admits that the
Revelation might even be news to her
foreign
[Music]
did your high school girlfriend know you
wrote that about her
that's a good question maybe maybe she
didn't I don't like telling anyone that
a song is
about somebody because they're just
visualizing who I'm writing about John
has been romantically linked to stars
like Taylor Swift Katy Perry Jennifer
Aniston and Jessica Simpson can we talk
about John Mayer for a hot second
I lost track of how many times for me
too you got broken up with yeah just
dated John on and off starting in 2006.
she detailed their time together in her
2020 Memoir open book and opened up to
E.T about what kept her coming back John
is an
extremely
um alluring
personality I mean he walks into a room
and he is the room like you you want to
be near him you want to be around him
he's so intelligent he's an amazing
musician
um and the songs that he would write I
mean they would bring me back it in
um his apologies would bring me back in
it was like a cycle that I couldn't even
keep up with now John describes himself
as single noting that he quit drinking
about six years ago and he says Being
Sober has changed his approach to
finding love you have to express your
anxieties you can't you can't just walk
over them by drinking you have to be
like here's what I'm anxious about and
when someone in life accommodates your
anxiety that's bonding as for what he's
looking for John wants a love that can
endure the tough stuff I'm always
supremely impressed by couples that I
know who are having a hard time but
haven't even considered breaking up
that's hot like that to me is the
hottest
[Music]